gang let's talk about that live stream
baby we're doing it live January 1st
Live from Tony seven o'clock Eastern
Standard time it's going to be a good
good time come hang out with us we're
gonna have some friends over we're gonna
have a little appearance from Denise and
Patty a couple of Pops come hang with
the boys yeah it's gonna be a good time
baby link is in the description
moment.co
ayg and that ain't it we got our third
show on sale right now at The Gramercy
theater let's go the army of garbage
came correct in New York City sold out
two shows we added our third links in
the description let's party baby Friday
February 3rd we'll see you there see you
there welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is are you
garbage little shall we sit down with
your favorite comedians and we find out
they're going to be classy yeah which
are just a big old piece of trash trash
trash trash trash trash I'm your host
James Foley coming at you on a beautiful
day we're down here in antuti's basement
she's upstairs making a nice fresh batch
of coquito okay for her new boyfriend
all right yeah I told him I'm not
calling him dad calling him poppy though
what's that Hooch starts flying around
you ever have that [ __ ] yeah I live in
the Heights dude what are you talking
about God damn it I carumba like eggnog
schmeg though put you on your ass uh-huh
my cows is coming at you from across the
table he is the CEO of Ru garbage he is
an international businessman he's my
best pal in the whole wide world KJ
Kevin James Ryan Hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate if you subscribe on iTunes all
video available on YouTube as you know
those numbers are
102. hi fever over there you gotta get
you to the hospital daddy put some
Tylenol in that thing yikes put in a
nice path let's cool it down we love you
gang uh and then obviously uh
um it's the greatest website of all time
it's life-changing shout out to Sam yam
Jack Conte the whole gang over there
patreon.com and if you do go over to
patreon.com gold paper check out slash
are you garbage you can bonus episodes
of hard feelings we've got a [ __ ] ton of
behind the scenes content stuff on the
road we got the Dave and Busters we got
our cribs we got down the shore we got
the camping video got everything you
ever want over there check it out I
think it's a bajillion hours legally
patent pending it's a good time over
there I'll tell you that shut up to that
hard feelings and how about a nice quick
shout out to our producer extraordinaire
the magic man makes us all look good
works the ones and two you crosses the
t's dots the eyes give it up for T-Bone
mcgruffins Toby McMullen okay what's up
dudes what's up pal you ever throw any
Brandy in your eggnog a little irking
jerk in there never had Brandy is that
Ian J oh yeah oh man I mean [ __ ]
these tall man
these two older kids I was in college a
freshman in college I was the only one
with a fake ID they were seniors they
made me go in and buy them e and J and I
didn't know what it was but I was too
much of a bubble Gummer to ask so I
asked the guy at the front desk I'm like
hey where do you keep the E and J he's
like over by the Brandy I'm like what's
that Bailey had [ __ ] him Bailey had hair
on my balls fake mustache on your
forehead
yeah I always stayed away from that [ __ ]
that's how you get molested you get
involved in that stuff emj that stuff
was too romantic that was in the that
was something Randy was for like [ __ ]
swingers dude
no just regular dude was drinking Brands
I didn't have a fireplace yeah I
couldn't drink it I'd never bear rug to
lay out on drink my bread spread my
butthole off my family was not a brand
that's what you were caught up in E and
J God damn no wonder you're off the
sauce Jesus Christ doing Brandy as a kid
is drinking Night Train in high school
look out uh erka jerk top tier is that
the name of it or is that what you and
your Escape board buddies called that
that's what everybody calls it I don't
think I've ever had I just knew e and J
I bought them something else too I was
like they gave me like 40 bucks to buy a
me and Jake you know Captain Morgan hey
baby this is close enough
another top tier booze nickname is the
Seagram's Gin bumpy face what's that the
bottle's all bumpy I don't know if I've
ever really I stayed away from gin too
because it gives you that nose
gives you a gin blossom Gin Blossom I
wrap it around like Rudolph yeah man my
stepdad's
step uncle or who somebody on his side
of family how old are them I carumba
I've never been seven people yeah and
keep Fred away from me will you okay
just make sure he comes by after dinner
okay I'm eating over here yeah I'm gonna
get the spaghetti in me before before he
starts rapping on the door yeah yeah
yeah
um that was tough uh [ __ ] wasn't gonna
God damn I had something good I lost it
I'm sorry I wanted to ask you is this
um
is it trash to take pills yeah
hang on a second uh-huh hang on one
second
um is it trash to take pills with no
water
yeah yeah yeah that's i i i i raw dog
him really yeah because I keep him
making Orca yeah I keep him in where
like where my shaving kit is I just I
just leave myself oh they're just out so
they have like hair stubble on them and
stuff no they're not they're not [ __ ]
Werther's Originals in my pocket they're
in their bottles okay but I just leave
everything in my shaving kit okay so I
don't gotta pack it up when we
skid that a lot on the road but you
never know when the heat's coming so
what's that have to do with having a
glass of water there's no water in in
that I don't I just go in there and like
where is that at it's in my Boudoir in
the in in in the bedroom
there's no water in there you act like
you're in the goddamn Sahara there's
water I'm not bringing a glass of water
in from the kitchen and are you gonna
walk into the kitchen with it in your
hand I got four I got three bottles I
gotta take my Lipitor my beta blockers
Nexium in my in my aspirin
four pills you put four pills in your
hand you're walking in the kitchen fill
up a glass of water that's my Winstrol
I'm gonna take that but that's a cream
is it what it's a cream no I know do you
hear the liver King got outed today
yikes or at some point he's all Jew he's
all Juiced up that [ __ ] guy the guy
who looks inflated the guy who looks
like steroids yeah he's on [ __ ]
steroids people say I'm on steroids
oh who says that a lot of people because
you're swollen because you're all puffy
all jacked up but is that bad to take I
wonder if it's bad for you to take it
like that I don't know T-Bone can you
get on that it's probably not good I'm
sure it says something with the liver
hey speaking of which I'm the king of it
um yeah it's probably something it's got
to do something with help but dissolve
otherwise the [ __ ] your stomach acids
are eating it yeah that ain't good yeah
maybe it is not I don't know
it increases the chance of getting stuck
in your esophagus
next thing you gotta [ __ ] you know
beta blockers in your throat burping up
beta blocker beta blocker burps man I
took I took I took fish oil for a little
while
yeah you smell like the bay dude burping
those things up so you got a bad crab
I had a bad soft shell earlier I promise
I'll take the heart attack I'm not
[ __ ] coughing that up yikes yeah that
stuff stinks uh it takes longer for them
to work and it can uh irritate the
lining of your esophagus which probably
ain't doing great for you already no
it's not all right I gotta get on the
water
um yeah I'll start taking them with
water I thought it might be bad I
thought of it this morning I wanted to
ask you boys if that's trash yeah I my
mine is also I keep all my stuff do you
take pills I didn't know if you took
pills yeah I take my uh hair growth
pills you do uh-huh that's my Advil when
I'm hungover is that the only thing you
take uh publicly yeah
a couple of Ed rockers
I'm on a heavy supply of Bluetooth
well that's chewable I don't need water
um kids walking around with a fresh one
all day uh no I just do uh just do the
the propec pro peace what about YouTube
when you want any medication no should
be though yeah something
get this guy a [ __ ] syringeful
Lorazepam stat [ __ ] Seroquel and soda
something calm this kid down that's off
his rackers
Ah that's probably not something we can
ask everybody
hey what are you [ __ ] what are you
boofing
I want everything about roller skates no
you can't ask that that's a private
thing not everybody wants to come up and
share the stuff sure what pills are you
on and who'd you vote for yeah two
things two things people do not like
talking about you know they change do
you know how the rule was that they
couldn't give um
they couldn't give results over the
phone
I think during the pandemic that's all
out the door yeah it's all out the door
because I got my I got all my blood work
and they're like if there's something if
there's something Shifty we'll call you
and she never called and all my stuff's
all all nice there's a couple of things
I don't know you look at it you're like
I want a phone call
sure let me know one time I got an SGD
test oh man that'll make me sometimes
you slip through the cracks and they
keep you in limbo and then you're about
to jump off the [ __ ] George
Washington Bridge or so I hear
this was my cholesterol and my blood
sugar oh I got jammed up at [ __ ] at
City MD man
oh man yikes they called me and they go
they go AIDS no herpes no chlamydia it
just says okay
this guy likes to party it's like what
does that mean
ah it's funny I call I had one time they
were like you're gonna they're like hey
we'll email you by the end of the day or
within 24 hours or whatever it was you
know what I mean like you'll get like a
secured email to log into your portal or
whatever
well that never came so I remember
sitting at work sweating it out right
just it's one and then you start I don't
know about everybody else out there but
I can I can convince myself I got
[ __ ] anything oh if I'm waiting on a
[ __ ] dice sure I got uterine cancer I
make myself believe if I need it so I'm
like
I knew I had menopause I know you're
pre-menopausal [ __ ] God damn it [ __ ]
knew it we're gonna have to do a
hysterectomy on you uh shouldn't watched
Golden Girls All Those Years shout out
to it baby
uh
uh goddamn B Arthur gave me menopause
um Blanche was a piece Rue McCoy wasn't
that well somebody Rue McClanahan
McClanahan yeah I can name them all
Betty White B Arthur uh Estelle Getty
and Rue McClanahan yeah yeah the Stars
took a run at her ah she was a freshman
I was a senior
um no and that's why so there's nothing
and then I called you know 48 hours or
whatever like way past the window of me
supposed to get an email and they're
like thank God you called we've been
trying to get a hold of me trying to get
a hold of me the [ __ ] do I got lady we
thought you were dead
still alive holy [ __ ] get the hospital
pal I panic pop that thing in a cooler
full of ice
scientists come in with that's the
spacesuits on like when they got eat
yikes shoot a net at me you got it in
milk like a tooth that fellow I want my
wiener my weiner got it was that what
you do you put it in melt your tooth
yeah they say when you're too I have a
shout out to my one of my best Pals
growing up ended up curb stomping
himself he was rollerblading he got
himself money he was rollerblading kid
doesn't mess around and caught a hanger
and [ __ ] fell and he just so happened
right on the curb she [ __ ] his whole
[ __ ] up they threw his teeth in [ __ ]
a glass of tubes almost to get milk on
my buddy that was not the time for
cereal they got a goddamn emergency over
here
at a time like this but if he ain't got
Cinnamon Toast Crunch I'll take a bowl
or a cup to go
if you have a cup of coffee get my head
on the street it's actually a pretty
good idea
also I'll give you two lumps and a
splash of cream huh have you got some
scrambies back there I'll do that as
well if we're doing it full breakfast
all the potatoes I'm trying to watch my
car and maybe some soup for my boy
do you have any oatmeal back there for
uh are you good you're all right hey
whistles you want anything
what the [ __ ] do you put it in milk for
it's so that's got to be a wives tale oh
no I think I did recently look this up
like maybe you're putting your teeth
back together no it does do like hey
keeps the root it can keep the root
alive or promote root growth or since
calcium it's all Ivory or whatever
[Laughter]
you [ __ ] elephant
yeah
a couple of poachers get me
uh milk contains certain substances that
help the tooth stay quote unquote alive
including sugars that the cells need to
survive yeah I don't think and you can
put it back I think you can put it back
in yeah I think like if the if it's all
you know well you don't crazy glue it
yeah like they do you don't do it at the
crib they take care of it for you it's
like an implant but if it's alive you
don't even think about it you put a dead
implant in there
one of my cousins one of my little baby
cousins just fell and the tooth went up
in into there hey oh yeah but they don't
take it out
they just let it nacho come out because
otherwise you'd have to go in there and
like do surgery on them
it'll grow out yeah they don't know they
don't really know that it's in there if
I knew that I would I'd get a [ __ ]
pair of pliers and yank it out that
would freak me out I remember I had I
don't even like the idea of wisdom teeth
I think that's real weird that dude and
they give me so much anxiety I don't ask
any questions about them and this
conversation's even making me nervous
have you had them what wisdom teeth you
haven't taken out no I can feel them all
right I got a couple of half these oh I
got one group
[ __ ] peeking around the corner I got
one's almost like a full-blown tooth I
don't know if you should be don't hurt
one time it did real bad I was drunk I'm
missing a tooth there so I almost
[ __ ] Tom Hanks didn't Cast Away with
him oh really no every once in a while
every once in a while it gets really
sore back there yeah that's the weather
or something you know what I mean keep
it moving not going to a dentist turn
the radio off have you had your wisdom
teeth taken out I have I went to visit
my mom my family she did it I got off
the plane and she goes oh yeah I
scheduled you to get your wisdom teeth
removed I was like what the [ __ ] I'm
here for vacation Jesus that's no fun
that's got they gotta you gotta let them
come out a little bit you can't just go
in there and get them one of the holes
is too deep they really dug it in so my
back tooth is like sagging backwards
kind of weird pair of pants in the 90s
[ __ ] crisscross over here I got some
jinko canines
yikes what about your tonsils your
tonsils taken out yep and when I what
the [ __ ] what's left of you you're still
floating ahead in a jar anymore Toby
they pulled me out of the ER oh he's
missing all this stuff but he still got
his foreskin he's like one of the planes
at the Intrepid Museum nothing on the
inside that is a deep cut
101 best planes that's dunk too what are
we doing here well they pulled me out of
this out of the operating room uh Mike I
was on my side my grandmother rolled me
over and they hadn't cauterized whatever
enough so I just started bleeding out of
my mouth and she was like what the [ __ ]
am I like oh whoops sorry like
this one's not done yet don't take all
your pain pills you gotta finish them in
the broiler for a little bit save me
some Percocets
yikes tonsils no I don't like that
either nope yeah I still got everything
I was supposed to have my adenoids taken
out because I was snoring when I was
seven
shout out to Dr Barbera Gary Barbera the
car dealership no Hannah Barbera one of
the barbarians from the Hannah Barber
love them
um he was uh are you being serious yeah
yeah he was he was related to his cousin
really all that Jetson's money yeah
shout out to Dr Barbera it was my doctor
it was my last primary care physician as
well no kidding he birthed me all the
way through like we was like Little
House in the prayer he was my doctor my
all of our doctors from the barbaros
from Hanna-Barbera or from Philly the
one his cousin I know his cousin was bar
bear from Hannah Barbera that's pretty
cool shout out to them yeah I don't know
uh if they are from Philly or not or
they you know that's just where they're
what's your adenoids I don't know T-Bone
get something on an adenoid and where
are the barberas from not FC Kerbeck
it's at the back of your nasal passages
they also I also don't have those they
took those out too
well your parents parents were selling
you for spare parts
you have you you
have a brother somewhere that stacked
away no wonder why you guys were in
Mexico for a while
waking up in a [ __ ] bathtub full eyes
they like Christian Bale and Ford versus
Ferrari throwing [ __ ] out of the car
holy [ __ ] that's crazy no tonsils no
wisdom teeth no adenoids you still have
your appendix yeah
both kidneys uh yeah yeah yeah I got
this I gotta set okay would you donate a
kidney and who would it have to be oh
this is fun that's a little hard
feelings but man would you give me a
kidney well here's the thing would you
take his kidney
you got two pints of Foley it's
borrowing stuff for my kidneys cherry
that's a Seinfeld line folks uh well the
good news is I wouldn't be eligible to
do any of that
oh you can't go under no yeah plus I'd
start doing heroin immediately why so
they wouldn't let me do it oh oh you
wouldn't give me one even if they were
like I would want to but I'm on heroin
I'd be disqualified yeah because you
started doing heroin so you didn't have
to give me a kidney that's how it starts
that's [ __ ] up dude you give me a
kidney sure really
huh yeah
probably lose a couple pounds too I
tighten up a little bit Yeah I'd give
you a kidney I don't think you would
T-Bone show up late I made a wrong turn
I die Flatline
if something happened to Luke I'd give
you one
wait if something happened to Luke then
we got no option
what if say so you wouldn't give do you
wouldn't save Toby's life because we
have Luke working for us that is that is
that your rationale only that if Luke
quit you would then save Toby's life if
Toby needed it it's a business
what are the dollars and cents on a
kidney you build them for it make them
pay you back over time
now I would give you both my kidney I
give you the shirt off my back are you
kidding me I don't need anything to
cover my boat
I'm now you're not getting a kidney okay
let's talk about Rex MD oh yes goes out
to all the limp noodles out there
emphasis on the D you know what I mean
boys you're having trouble getting it up
I know I am yeah you need something what
are we doing let's go no gang we all
need to help at times getting the old
[ __ ] joystick working sure you know
what I mean Rex MD makes getting generic
Viagra in Cialis easy and simple and do
yourself a favor if you need some hit
them up oh yeah baby uh the Rex MD has
made the whole process very simple and
just a few clicks of a button I went on
a website Bing Bang Boom for research
purposes obviously give me the maximum
shrink stuff huh you hear that uh
something you can swing from let's go I
talked to a medical professional you
create a personalized plan and get the
products discreetly shipped straight to
your door within two days Viagra can't
come around Viagra can cost around 90 a
pill recognized generic Viagra is just
as effective and as low as a two dollars
a pill baby moving it on the blue uh
bucks a nut let's go more than just ED
medication check out Rex MD's other
medications for sexual health hair
growth pain relief and sleep aid or XMD
is FDA approved clinically tested and
USA and the U.S U.S licensed Pharmacy
Rex MD has already helped over 300 000
guys gain confidence quickly and
conveniently and they're here to help
you act now baby here's the turkey act
now to take advantage of their best deal
yet by heading to rexmd.com garbage our
exclusive deal will save up to 90
percent off where you're only going to
be paying two dollars per dosage starter
packs of generic Viagra or Cialis are
now available for our listeners to get
started that's rexmd.com garbage for up
to 90 off they're giving it away give
the gift a pleasure this holiday season
with Rex MD baby do it okay let's talk
about that liquid IV baby I love that
liquid IV yeah let's talk about kicking
off 2023 right I know you're hungover
fueling your best self baby yeah get
yourself some liquid IV it's absolutely
fantastic hydrates you a lot quicker
than regular water like a boozer oh yeah
and it comes in 10 fantastic flavors
we're talking grape lemon lime and my
favorite tropical punch ah big man does
Love A trappy Punch uh get one head on
straight one stick of liquid IV and 16
ounce of water hydrates you two times
faster or more efficiently than water
alone baby the single serve packaging
helps you stay hydrated on the go the
good folks over there liquid Ivy were
nice enough to send us boxes of this
stuff there you go I got it coming out
my ears I got the whole family hooked on
it it's good stuff I use it after a
night of boozing I use it this morning
not gonna lie I'm gonna I'm on a little
liquid IV right now concord grape baby
takes me back to Childhood it's all
right uh contains five essential
vitamins B3 B5 B6 B12 you need bees we
got them and they got vitamin C contains
three times the electrolytes than
traditional sports drinks made with
premium ingredients liquid ID is free
from gluten dairy and soy here's the
turkey grab your liquid IV and bulk
nationwide at Costco or you can get 20
off if you go to liquid iv.com use the
code garbage at checkout that's 20 off
anything you order when you shop for
better hydration today using promo code
garbage at liquid iv.com do it no of
course yeah
if I had to yeah my family tight friends
yeah if it was going to save their life
of course
yeah how close of a friend I want to
find out where the line is Oh I only got
the two years I got you too Tom I mean
we all don't need them but I'm saying
what like I only got two kidneys fellas
all right now uh yeah tight friends and
family
okay
could I have one of your eyes
which one I don't know the lazy one
assume they both are
the goddamn Family episode yeah what are
we doing here with all this kidney talk
uh when you sign up for the patreon over
there we will ask your garbage question
on here it's just the best way to do it
folks so who's patreons get Numero Uno
priority they're flying first classes
patreon that's right sure they pay a
couple bucks a lot of perks well worth
it and once you go you can't leave we
should have a perfect it's the first
class this is the first clip it's
business class of patreon we should have
a perk plan that'd be nice perk plan
Diamond status gold status Oh I thought
we were still talking pills
that's it we get a bunch of pills if I
gave you a kidney sure that yeah there
you go all right fair enough there you
go
um all right this one is from Mike Hawk
which I think is a my [ __ ] uh
ever wore cologne on a beach
that's a real Italian thing I presume
cologne on a beach uh no it was never a
real big Cologne guy I wasn't in high
school a little bit in college if I was
going out I'd spruce up with some Polo
sport or Polo black polo Sports all
right that's the blue the blue that was
a little too sweet Polo black really got
the lady the green one was nice the
original no that's the trashiest the
green one really I believe so I was just
talking to Tommy Pope about this I
wonder what he uses uh uh I don't know I
think he did tell me I don't think he
does much though little dab well dab
yeah it's all his pheromones coming off
guys pumping out [ __ ] sexy
um I work alone every day what that's
what I don't know what it is Marlboro
Reds what are you talking about all
right we're calling I have cologne on
now how do you not know what it is
though uh I can't remember the BR I
can't remember the brand
um bod no it's nice something nice
it's like you would know I don't but I'm
not buying it I have two bottles I have
one that I take with me when we go on
the road and I have another one that's a
little bit sweet I've never known you to
smell nice not bad but also not nice
that's because I don't I don't go over
the top with it it neutralizes
everything neutralize there's a lot of
bad smells that that's neutralized yeah
dude okay it's like the Iron Dome okay
that makes Patriot missile system
one of those things that makes sense
okay all right uh yeah I don't even
think I have cologne
at all cologne deodorant spray got over
this yeah it's a whole thing but I just
use a little bit I put a little on my
neck in case so when I give the hug when
I do that when you know you hug somebody
like that just nice little it smells
good put a little on my wrists when
you're jerking off make it feel like
another dude
uh rub yeah rub that together a little
bit and then this is Sebastian
Maniscalco he he showed you how to do it
unlike an Instagram video or something
like that you do that you do that it's
like seven spritzes and then you put
your clothes on and then you go one two
three four or something like that then
you walk into the Mist yeah that's how I
do it Brett Ernst is a big guy yeah it
was learned I think okay
Rosie O'Donnell used to do 40 squirts
she said really squirts of cologne of
perfume okay that could be alone I don't
know
it could be Brute
shout out to Brooke shout out to Rosie I
used to watch her show all the time I
loved it the Rosie O'Donnell show is 11
A.M I believe 10 a.m on sick days even
before that when she hosted that
stand-up show on VH1 I loved her and
that I think that was before back before
I was banging and she's in something now
is she in the old man
with um no she's in [ __ ] uh American
Gigolo on Showtime I haven't watched
with uh John Bernthal oh she's fantastic
she plays like um the lady that runs
Cadmus For Suicide Squad
oh Martha Waller yes
um is it Martha Waller ah Amanda Wall
Amanda Waller she has a very a very
Amanda Waller Vibe great yeah she's
really good in it shout out to Rosie
shout out to Rose 40 pumps that's what
she said I remember things that's crazy
yeah 40 squirts I've seen that video
when I have my tonsils taken out no one
was home uh all right let's see here
this one's from janky uh you or anyone
you know ever claimed to be the victim
of a family curse
I've been told I had the Irish curse but
that's just me I know I do
that
um no family curses a lot of there's a
lot in my family and in my surrounding
God if it wasn't for bad luck I'd have
no luck at all right and a lot of God
damn I can't catch a [ __ ] break the
Kennedys were cursed they say
I also I thought there was a you know
there was 50 of them they were all
alcoholics you're bound to lose a couple
to an accident here and there you know
what I mean the [ __ ] I got one flying a
plane got another guy driving drunk what
are we doing here yeah I don't mess with
that stuff yeah curses stay away not my
kind of not my kind of vibe but yeah no
uh I feel like to be like real like uh
Old Country type [ __ ] you know what I
mean Gypsy type stuff curse the family
took so you take somebody's land that's
what they do yeah curses yeah some sort
of ancient burial as well or something I
just found out that uh or I just saw
that Washington Square Park is buried on
is a huge burial ground no I thought
that was Thompson Square Park now this
is a Washington Square I'm sure Thompson
Square too Thompson Square Park I
believe is where they used to bury all
like dead it was a Potter's field that's
what they call this field where they
bury the uh ashes no were they buried
Hot Josh Potters the whole pot our whole
Potter crew down there talking about
cursed yeah yeah the whole family
um walk in your eyesight goes bad no
they have
The Potter's Potter's ground is where
they bury people that don't have any
family and stuff like that I believe
that was 20 000 people buried under
there yeah yeah yeah that's what they
say Thompson Square Park that's why it's
like extra seedy at night that's why all
the Kooks go there where all the crazy
Thompson Square Park well the crazies go
there because they say it's like always
where they would bury all the homeless
yeah
yeah back in like you know whatever same
thing the Washington Park in Philly
where's that at it's downtown by the
Liberty Bell
um it's an old burial ground but I think
that's nuts why wouldn't you think about
soldiers and stuff like that take them
out the city limits throw them on a
horse and carriage do something I don't
know barium and sea we have barrier
right next to the [ __ ] Bodega what
are we doing here no yikes
um all right this one's from Foley lies
I didn't come up with the name fair
enough uh he's ever been to an erotic
Expo
no no I don't they don't make I've been
to one Expo I think I've talked about it
was like the windows oh no I used to
work I used to work you went to the car
show
I had been to the car show
because my boy's dad worked in the Auto
industry so we would like it would go
with that but um no I went to one member
remember at the like uh Valley Forge
Convention Center or whatever one of
them
here and on the radio you know it was
stickers and it was like rock and roll
or something I don't know what it was it
stunk right away we walked in I was like
[ __ ] dorks and my dad's like what'd I
tell you I knew this was gonna suck I
was like all right man let's just do a
quick laugh again see if there's any
chicks here we hit the ground round get
out of here [ __ ] it's a goddamn football
game on
um
I owe the AVN Awards look like they'd be
a good time yeah that's also like kind
of pretty intertwined with comedy I know
like a bunch of people have hosted I
think I think Norton's hosted them a
bunch imagine there's a lot of sex going
on yeah man I think you go up in those
rooms it's all freaking naughty really
yeah yeah yeah
and my hands on that just do a little
watching I mean you get the greats
together they're gonna play the game I
know what are you talking about you
don't think there's a pickup game after
the NBA All-Star weekends to Pro Bowl
you know like they're meeting up at the
Y and having a dunk contest
yeah now I've never been to a sex Expo
now I don't know I wouldn't feel I see
them a lot where you know uh I feel like
we're followed by I see that on
Instagram a lot like there was just one
in Jersey like not too far like homeless
pimp win or something really yeah just
like documented or something like that
those the the Expos of all kinds just
give me bad vibes it's just like the
black curtains or the blue curtain it's
just all like real shoddy put together
I'm trying to sell you something yeah
like we're supposed to sit here and
believe this is the world's best dildo
what are we talking about here
but how do I know I'm gonna need to see
this demonstrated I'll take my pants off
which way is the bathroom
all right this one's from Rumple bum
skin ten dollar homie never had one red
what's the trashiest item to keep your
spare changing we've talked about this a
couple of times you have a Poland Spring
right you have a half a pollen spring
I have yeah but it's not the it's not I
I'm switching over to I can't really
have two small Poland Springs cut with
the top cut off like these
bigger than that Jesus yeah it's bad
that's there well I never well I never
was able to keep change I always needed
it it was part of my [ __ ] net worth I
always had
to go cash it in at something that's the
trashiest I can't see anything trash
here what is that you that yes a [ __ ]
cut off Poland's plastic where do you
keep your change I keep it in a little
drawer a little dish in the drawer how
much you gotta have more that's got to
be full though I bet you wake up with a
dollar fifty stuck to your body every
day I know oh man
we used to have a huge dude
that's that Toby I'm like a goddamn
wishing well a couple of pickles
yeah man for a while when I would have
you fall asleep on the couch it's a wrap
free pandemic when I would have like
change in my pocket yeah dude I would
wake up [ __ ] quarters nickels you
make a long distance phone call
yeah that's bad 100 just sticking to me
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] is that
I don't really have a lot of change
okay so what do you die if you gotta do
something when I was waiting tables I
had tons of it and I would always I
would put it in there but we use it for
the laundry so it Cycles in and out of
everything you don't have a card
no a card for the laundry yeah yeah I
don't know anything about that ours old
school quarters whoa yeah
wow okay guys come and collect it every
Friday night yeah no we have a credit
card system we have a nice part of town
look at you yeah pretty much loses the
car to constantly yeah yeah put 20 bucks
on lose it panic
that's what it is
um but I'm switching over to one of the
big ones because I recently got the big
yeah that's what that's what it should
that's classy so it's not classy because
now we're like where do you put that
you stick it over in the corner by the
plant and then you save all that money
up and then you go on a little vacation
with it you can save up home you can set
up like 10 grand in one of those things
10 grand in there no I don't think so
ten granding change
Penguins a lot of money dude four grand
maybe I'll give you I'll give you two
that'll get you on a cruise we should go
on a cruise boat I wanna I don't
ironically wanna go on a cruise okay is
that crazy
don't doesn't that seem like it would be
all right you go hit the beat a couple
of beaches it's three days you get some
fun you get some sun you got since I
found out they root through your bags
also did you ever see when they get all
when they hit bad Seas those things
start tipping yeah everybody's doing
that I mean it's like one in a billion I
don't know those life the lifeboats have
gotten a lot better oh yeah
what do you think the most amount of
pennies that has ever been cashed in a
Coinstar is in a coin star pennies at a
coin twenty thousand dollars ten Grand
thirteen wow a million betties that's a
lot of pets pretty good point three
million 13 g's look at that
a million pennies is thirteen thousand
dollars Yeah by a guy named Ben Franklin
the Ben Franklin
you is that a real oh the real Ben
Franklin was was what do you invent the
free invented electricity he goes you
know what I gotta do something with
these pennies
but crying forgot the Coinstar part okay
I mean unless he invented it
stuck the pennies in there and then and
then threw it out so because he knew
Society wasn't ready for it it says a
five gallon jug could hold maybe 5K
that's pretty good that's all right get
your get you on a Carnival Cruise you
ain't hitting the buffet now you're
gonna have to sneak in your own booze
[ __ ] that but rooting through my luggage
then they leave you somewhere what do
you mean they leave you on an island if
you if you don't get if you don't go
back to the shipping time they they
ghost you there's a next one coming
around oh [ __ ] that yeah I don't think I
could just do that's what the locals get
a hold of you I couldn't do the the
rooms I'd have to have like a nice big
roses those State rooms are I hate
probably a couple of bucks no window too
I don't think I I would I would have a
panic attack I think what if you were
below the sea level too and you had a
window I don't think they do that no no
they don't tag me what are you talking
about they're not putting you in the
galley
down there with the mice and stuff like
that
I think there's mice on those ships it's
like a city the mice don't the mouse
don't know
for all he knows he's he's going to
Puerto Vallarta he's kicking it
I'm on vacation saved up my panties yeah
now
I don't like that [ __ ] those things tip
over [ __ ] I don't think I don't think
the water if the water goes bad
everyone's got botulism they leave you
stranded out there in the harbor for a
couple of days
then it's Lawless yeah I think you're
you're really uh I don't think it's that
bad I mean dude there's there there was
just one that they just led into Port
from the pandemic what yeah a couple of
weeks two years later yeah they were out
there uh you got to get eyes I'm pretty
sure no way I'm pretty sure what you
should have been on it for what two and
a half years uh listen I want to believe
you but that seems a little that would
be something that would be there'd be
movies about that already there would be
[ __ ] that would be all over
everything I don't know
is he right he's probably right these
are the things he ends up being right
about but the thing is the way he
describes him I don't know how to look
them up yeah
vote from two years ago finally cruise
ship pandemic that's what I did but
everything's from 2020. yeah because
that's not true I mean if that just
happened I would still be in the news
are you are you genuinely are you
misremembering this are you making this
up
it might have been a movie okay
it might have been the Poseidon
Adventures
do you find anything about a giant
octopus
I could have been watching Captain
Phillips before I fell asleep
now there was something where
uh somebody tested positive on a ship
not that long ago and they left them out
there for a couple of weeks for a while
positive of what coven they're not still
they're not good dude that's a there's
no way they're jamming up a bunch I'm
telling you man they were out in the
harbor and it wouldn't go near I'm not
saying you're wrong on that but that
seems crazy they were throwing
sandwiches at him get out of here you
heathens
hahaha
800 people got got covered on a cruise
in Sydney okay hold on this uh November
12 2022. there you go 800 people
I mean but hey everybody's got it you
can still bang and stuff we're all drunk
still make out
think about it everybody in the ship hey
mono hey what are we doing you know
tomorrow's not guaranteed that whole
type of thing I mean I'd be closing on
dudes left and right
[Laughter]
you're always on the poop deck
uh all right this one's from Jake uh big
man's not gonna get it but the 10 is it
garbage that the only phone number I
have memorized belongs to
Toby McMullen do you know wait that you
no this is the question from Jake is it
garbage is it the only phone number I
have memorized belongs to 867-5309
[Laughter]
-1-1 Mike Jones
who's Mike Jones do you know that he
might be too young now you're not maybe
you're too young for that who okay it's
got to be something in a rap song it is
Mike Jones probably in
2003 came out with a what's up Bob Mike
Jones hit Mike Jones The Hook was call
my cell phone and he said the number
281-330 hit Mike Jones up on the low
281-330-8004
okay hey Mike jobs hit Mike Jones up on
the low because Mike Jones about to blow
and when that [ __ ] dropped I mean it was
everybody was calling it and he could
barely get through and it was just like
a voicemail like yo you've reached Mike
Jones oh that's pretty cool yeah hit
Mike Jones up whatever whatever because
people were doing that for a while
recently where you could text them or
call them or something yeah texting's a
big thing like with like a lot of comics
or like people you know does it go to
their actual phone I would highly doubt
people Sal vulcano has people texting
them all day
no it's just I think it's more of like
it's like the email thing of like you
get a text when I'm in your area you
know it's like hey oh I got that kind of
thing you know cool uh just another form
of communication I know my mom's my
dad's rest in peace are there any uh my
brothers are there any landlines you
still know from your buddies girl I
still remember yeah I know everybody's
first cell phone like Vinnie with the
skinny Ryan
[Applause]
me I know my cousins I know my boy uh
Robbie Hutchinson's old number
um my boy Riley's number
I remember their cell phone and their
house numbers
and I remember the number that I used to
call for my first
um hooker no close
uh my first associate that I met
sure you know the guy pharmaceutical
sales representative
by pharmaceutical sales rep was that
Pfizer who was that it was Merc
it was perk Mercado uh okay yeah yeah
that doesn't go away no yeah that's
burned in there remember the last thing
I say before I die
917.
I'll be back
call me back quick I got a party
uh yeah that's yeah I'm talking about
drugs I don't do you know your do you
know your ladies number no I don't know
mine either it was too late in the game
yeah it's nothing nothing disrespectful
it's just too late in the game because
I'll tell you when I hear something
crazy no save that for all fair yeah I
want to hear something ah so I got my
first cell phone
42.
[Music]
um
when did the iPhone come out uh 2000
let's call it six eight nine seven eight
definitely six because I was in New York
when it first no I wasn't a freshman the
first time I saw one maybe 2016. [ __ ]
this guy's sleeping at the wheel over
there sorry the computer was updating
I think Tebow needs an update we bought
you the new oven cooked something will
you Jesus Christ is Broad uh first
iPhone 2007. oh really okay so
I probably got a cell phone in 2003 if a
flip phone that sounds about right and I
never put anybody's number in it I just
memorized everybody's number
I don't know I was paranoid so I never
played paranoid about what just in
general I just didn't trust no I mean
what about you mean I don't know I just
didn't put anybody's number and I had
zero numbers in my contact
and I would just I would just I would
just memorize all the numbers it was
only about 10 numbers that I had to
memorize my mom my dad my brother
um
uh my new sales rep associate sure when
I got trouble his co-workers
and he got transferred Upstate to a new
new section new territory
um and then like my bosses at the time
and a couple other friends that was it I
would know
I knew their numbers for a long time but
then at a certain point I just gave in
and just started putting numbers in
there and now I don't know who the [ __ ]
I know my mom's
yeah I mean I know anything that hasn't
changed yeah
I remember when people were changing
when remember when when you change
carriers yeah yeah dude [ __ ] that you
couldn't take over numbers no
yeah yeah I remember crazy I told you I
started fresh not too long ago it felt a
decade ago you did felt nice yeah
when I moved to New York I think right
before I moved to New York I started I
really wiped the wipe the Slate clean
put it on your review huh putting this
whole goddamn town on my review got out
uh that I think I was kicked off of uh
the plan I was on uh due to some family
ongoings uh yeah I had to go out on my
own
do it for myself there you go zero zero
zero some whack-ass area code not a
minute
yeah give me a call it's 999. what the
[ __ ] get out of here yeah uh 215-610-917
or 2110
no I'm doing a good area
610-215 Philly oh it starts at two on
five two one five is the Primo sure I
think we were always 610 yeah The Burbs
to the West were always six one six one
oh two one five man myself
um two one two New York that's the
that's the best sure two one two
um but that wasn't cell phone it was
917. now they got three four seven I
think my broad's got a 917
917 is legit three four seven I don't
even know
you're getting drugs text me your number
I'll call you now it's like you you
never if you're inputting a number now
it's on
what do you mean like two one five it's
always clicked or sent or oh yeah of
course I get pissed off when I go to the
the website and you can't copy and paste
the thing when it doesn't just pop up
you got to go back and look and then I
forget and go back again pain in the ass
you know what I found you I got you
what this might blow your brain a little
bit touch the back of the Apple what
that does something
I don't know
what is it the G-Spot and finally
squirts on you touch the back of the
Apple yeah if you touch the back of the
Apple it does something turns the phone
on or something
you can you can program a double tap on
the back of your phone to you know
activate your camera or yeah like that
yeah on the new ones not mine yeah right
on any of them
look at that learn something new every
day I'm a fat man what was going to put
on my mind I'm a [ __ ] nerd dude
yeah we don't have you here because
you're cool dude
now get his name's buttons get to
Googling
what's gonna blow my mind
if you do you know how you can kill apps
sure right you know you can bring that
up you know how you can do that or no
yeah yeah I gotta do that well like tell
you the numbers there you just you can
do that and just jump back and forth
oh looking at it yeah yeah I know that
okay
I don't think you did but fair enough
um all right here let's see this uh
moving on this one's from DJ Van Damme
uh shout out to I believe was at the La
Jolla show the van dams remember oh yeah
shout out shout out for the whole van
the whole Squad
they're all dressed like professional
wrestlers but still man that La Jolla
show really that's a great Club there's
something else we'll be back
uh DJ Van Damme ever fallen out of a
tree
absolutely dude I don't know I don't
really like like took a career broken
bones Ryan not out of a tree I was
pretty Nimble back in my day before I
started putting on the weight uh but I
uh yeah it was pretty Nimble it's pretty
good we climbed trees all the time never
I don't think I ever really fell I fell
out of a tree fort out the window like
the old west the window yeah who had the
blueprints on that thing it was the Toll
Brothers well it was in the addition I
went to the solarium now we had a pretty
tight
um
tree fort that my dad made on the
property you're in a wood somewhere on
the property
yeah we weren't witches what the [ __ ]
build a tree fort in the woods you build
that's an on property thing no we've
always built no who the [ __ ] wants to
hang due to tree for does it get away
from your fancy your own little place
it's your own you're already up in there
what you're not in the woods yeah where
else do you build tree for really what
the [ __ ] could there's a tree fort dude
in your backyard you can't yank it in
there
yeah always in the woods smoke your
cigarette real little flip your Maggie
yes oh was I
flipped thumb through your thumb through
your reading materials you know what I
mean no we always in the woods really
yeah now we only I only ever I built
like a little uh uh me in this Buffet
I built the Ponderosa
did happy hour deals it was a good time
um no me and this me and this this girl
that I grew up with this neighbor we
built like a little uh like it was a
clubhouse was the place where we could
play doctor
behind her garage yeah
um you guys were building a Sex Dungeon
for each other that's what you're doing
but what a little privacy
I get it I went to the doctor as a child
myself with a name oh yeah
um but at my my that the house the first
house that we had my dad we had we had
like four apple trees like four bang and
apple trees in the backyard
we had one that like really it had like
a nice like flat surface you can sure so
he put down some uh some plywood and
hooked it up made a little window and
stuff like that had a little rope that
came down it was nice I fell out of that
yeah I think I got pushed out of it to
be honest with you
okay here Jerk It Off I got no goddamn
privacy from your mouse breathing down
my neck I think one of my cousins or my
brother threw me out I remember one time
uh uh I put I tried it it was at my
dad's house my dad's house never I
didn't have like friends around my dad
because I went to school still at my
mom's sure so like I didn't socialize
with the kids around my dad's and then
he would just take me to my I mean it
was only like whatever seven minutes
away or whatever he would take me to all
of my friends from you know of the house
I grew up in
so like I always try to like have fun
there and I was like I want to build a
tree house for like when like my friends
come over or whatever like a fort in the
there was one tree and it was real thick
and I took a bunch of uh
remember that like wire it would be like
above like the laundry machine it was
like the wire shelving the white wire
shelving kind of you can't you know what
I mean wire it's like why it's a metal
yeah metal but yeah it's a covered in
like the the white rubber yes yes yes
like cut it for however long of course
well he had a bunch of that left over
and like I put it up in the I put it up
in the backyard to like sit on it in the
trees because it was like real thick and
then oh like I did that in this you know
August or whatever that's for like a
gallon of Tide not your fat ass but then
the [ __ ] Autumn rolled around and all
the leaves fell out I remember standing
at those like doing the dishes like
looking out the windows like the [ __ ]
did you put in a tree I'm talking about
[ __ ] ran out what the [ __ ] did you do
to the jokes can I see you later get a
little perv Nest up there just [ __ ]
beeping oh Peep and get me out there
oh man just get me did you ever see that
have you ever as a at any point even in
New York or anything ever you catch uh
you catch anything in the window a
glimpse of anything yeah especially as a
kid it would have been would have
obviously a bit more then we see people
boning when we were in LA in that one
one building
last time we were in La one of the times
there was people banging in the window
or am I crazy you might be crazy
um
New York
I always catch a guy I remember I called
a neighbor who was like you know you
would just be like watching TV you know
she would like walk across or whatever
she watching
I'm in her closet
I mean you believe this broad had the
nerve to shower naked
goddamn disgrace
hey honey do me a favor turn that up
here now you missed the spot huh turn
the TV up so you can't hear the Drone
can't hear me breathing
um now one time uh a girl I was dating
lived in a dorm and across the street
was on 14th Street
uh there was an apartment building and I
think I saw some lady like closing like
getting she was undressed and then
closed when I walked over the clothes
yeah yeah my buddy uh heard me whistling
I'm sure people have seen me I roll
around heavy bike in there sure buck
naked
fresh and I'm always I oh the curtain in
in the in in the in the office is always
all the way up and then that's where I
go after I get out of the shower I gotta
get I gotta go to the bathroom quick and
let let the let the let the temp cool
start cooling the yeah pull down the
reactors a little bit Yeah 100 otherwise
you got another Chernobyl on your hands
uh and I it's always up and I'm like God
damn it and I gotta walk over my towel
over my little Noodle and [ __ ] just
pull it you always do like a half of
this or that like you just think if you
move quick enough and it's dark enough
yeah yeah you got to pretend like you're
making a little effort sure you know
what I mean anyone you think you're a
[ __ ]
so floozy walking around your own
apartment trying to be a little naughty
ah yeah my buddy uh used to live in
Midtown and all the time
in like one of those high rises like not
too far from here or whatever yeah
all the time it would just be like
shooting like naked
pics and stuff like Instagram or
whatever just like [ __ ] all like out
on the decks and stuff like that just
really being like I don't care who sees
this type thing that's erotic oh yeah I
wish I had I mean I don't care what
people you know I'm pretty comfortable
in my with my skin which I shouldn't be
I'm aware of that
um but I wish I had one of those bodies
just I'd just walk around you know I
wish I had the confidence to do that
sure just well we're all glad you don't
just for me and the rest of the
pedestrian the rest of the citizens in
New York that's the confidence but I
wish I had one of those bodies yeah what
do you think we were a hot chick yeah me
too walk around blowing everybody I get
it
yeah it's a it's a fine line between oh
and oh yeah yeah it really is
you ain't funny
I wish I had one of those bodies oh you
don't say do you
a tiny little one um all right this one
so we could do a couple more here uh
this one's from Tyler uh ten dollar
board member never had one red shout out
to the Big T how garbage is it to fix
something with a chewed piece of gum my
aunt had one of the vents in her car
held in place with a piece of gum she
had been chewing and it stayed there for
well over six months whoa
that's tough I'll give it to you in a
jam if you're on a road trip and it
breaks you got to do what you gotta do
to say did she fix with it the vent in
her car
the vent what would the gum do like if
it like fell down or something bro I
don't know I don't have any information
it was crack a piece of plastic cracked
okay and she did something with a piece
of gum Dough because I used to use when
I had braces I would use gum to cover up
because if something was cutting your
cheek
that's yeah I mean gum belongs in your
mouth true not with braces but it never
worked for me like when I'd watch the
80s shows and they'd like use gum to
like they use like the gum and the
wrapper to break into like a window or
something like that that [ __ ] never
worked it never stuck yeah what Silly
Putty was kind of a scam too
I was big I like I I was I was big on
the putty yeah yeah a little bit didn't
always work for me well I remember you
used to like put it on the newspaper
didn't what it didn't really do much
though yeah it was like bad Play-Doh put
it on the newspaper that was it yeah can
you show your friend he was like yeah
I've seen it before all right well I'll
see you I'll be over here with my Slinky
if anything I'll be jerking off in a
tree yeah
did you see me did you have any tinfoil
on any antennas
sure we not tin foil we had some
because we didn't have cable I think
I've talked about this we didn't have
cable upstairs so me and my brother
would carry uh like the TV you would see
out of a movie like out of an 80s movie
it was like you know probably
12 inch screen but like a three foot box
type thing heavy heavy and we would
carry that from room to room because it
had bunny ears and the bunny ears were
whack so we had some sort of like
it was all we were always building on
the antenna system sure you know what I
mean it was like a hang or a key ring
something to to jockey it so you could
get an extra Channel or two where was
that coming from the satellite yeah
that's what you were picking up I get I
guess I mean it wasn't you would just
plug the TV into the wall yeah it's just
satellite you just plug the TV into the
wall radio waves that's the same thing
to me
are you here to tell me satellite and
radio waves aren't the same thing one of
them is on the planet one of them is in
space was there attack they might as
well both be in space yeah what are you
talking about
one of them's on the play okay well
technically it breaches the atmosphere
hey buttons this guy just guys just
finding out he's a nerd hey
Strat is dork
shut up before I come over and give you
a wedgie yeah oh you're nuts
I just
I hit enter too fast with the search I
typed in bunny ears and now I got a
bunch of sexy you guys you guys should
be two younger men do you remember the
vert and horizontal on TVs what do you
mean the the vertical and horizontal it
would sometimes go like that or go like
that oh the track not track was it track
no track oh tracking on a V8 on a VHS
remember that you thought I was that was
[ __ ] I got it if you knew about
tracking [ __ ] it up down up down
remember having a re-auto program a TV
if you unplugged it and plugged it back
in it would have to count through like
one two three four yeah gotta reorder
and sometimes like a channel wouldn't
show up you're like Channel Nine's not
showing up anymore go unplug it to the
auto pro let me see it but every once in
a while everyone's in a great while one
that shouldn't be would kind of pop up a
little bit or would catch it a little
bit yeah we never that was like I mean I
remember watching naughty as a kid I was
real young am I you know with like my
brother my cousins and they would be
watching it like down the shore or
whatever when all the all the all the
moms went out to the Springfield though
get loosened up yeah get loosened up and
hit on the down Folk
we'd all be we'd all be back at Aunt
Patty's a bunch of little Stingers I was
too young to understand what it was but
I remember they would like you know I
remember seeing my first boob go from
like a boob to like a you know like turn
into a jellyfish that was gonna happen
when I take your broth Jesus Christ
you don't reverting horizontal on TVs
man I'm old
yeah I'm a nerd you're old he's bald
what are we doing hey cut that
they're gonna know Three Musketeers huh
Toby just blew our cover
folks he is not bald
it's the bunny ears
um all right let's do two more and then
we gotta wrap it up this one's from Matt
uh have you ever had a family member
been reprimanded for smoking at a gas
pump
never reprimanded but my dad would smoke
it my dad was big on smoking where he
didn't care he was like rules don't
apply to me do you turn it you turn the
car off when you get gas do I yes yeah I
don't even like playing with the cell
phone
that people were going up in Flames over
that shut the [ __ ] up oh yeah I leave it
running the car yeah oh no it's 2022.
they fixed that I'm sure
I I think it's right it's combustion no
right excuse me
hey whatever you listen to is your
business put a pair of shoes I'm a rock
and roll man
you thought it was music
yeah like uh contemporary combustion
music when you leave your car running
while pumping gas you're essentially
just incinerating the fumes that come
off the gasoline yeah this could be
extremely dangerous yeah yeah even now
dude if you stop in Jersey they say turn
your car off don't they not now I
haven't had to I will now
I mean I can't believe that's the thing
you're not paranoid about as dude it's
so weird you have so much paranoia but
there's they don't do it at the on the
racetrack they don't shut the Nascar car
off
so that's what you're equating this to
hey if Dale Jr does it and I'm sure Dale
Earnhardt senior was smoking in there
yeah he was having a heater we were such
a Dale Earnhardt fan how could you die
we were an Intimidator family we had
Flags he's got a banner he's got like a
30-foot Banner that says the Intimidator
I'm not even I'm not big into NASCAR
obviously but man Dale Earnhardt talk
about a [ __ ] man's man real cowboy
talk about cut short God damn I think he
was like 58 when he went still on the
track God didn't even look like that bad
of a collision but it is
um yeah I don't I haven't been turning
off the car I think you should I don't I
mean new cars new technology
it's it's not about the technology it's
about that you're putting a A
combustible thing into your engine
gasoline is wild flammable and so are
the fumes the fumes are what catch yeah
so what I don't understand
if the car is off it's still hot in
there right
yes but there's not an explosive
reaction happening with the little
things I've seen the Valvoline
commercials the little the little pumps
are going up and down yeah because your
car is is exploding the gasoline I don't
even know if they use them anymore what
whatever he's talking about
it's a new car it's a new vehicle
yeah let me see if I can get to the
bottom of this people are screaming
the fire risk is that the fumes burn not
the liquid this could lead to an
explosion so before you fuel off shut
the car off and leave it off and unplug
any devices that you think you may be
charging Jesus
man I've been [ __ ] rolling
[ __ ] I didn't know that gas myth yeah
Smith there we go
well if you only have you ever
considered starting your engine back up
to see exactly how uh oh that's nuts I
would never start it why it's in there
oh no I must oh man that's like a Car
Bomb [ __ ] Al-Qaeda that's crazy
you nuts
um it's because they use dump cans in
NASCAR so they have their fuels injected
into the car incredibly rapidly which
minimizes the risk of the fumes igniting
all right so I need a dump can
you call your underwear
we gotta wrap it up gang we [ __ ] love
you
um
how about tickets are on sale right now
to uh our show our theater show in New
York City New York at The Gramercy
theater get those tickets let's sell
this [ __ ] thing out gang what are we
doing we can't sell out shows here in
New York City I'm packing it up it's a
wrap The Gramercy theater big deal for
us grab those tickets come out and see
us we love you to death and we'll see
you next week